katie moulua's jazz and folk influence
sound may be new for some american
audiences
[Music]
but she's spent the last 15 years as one
of great britain's top artists
[Music]
her first seven studio albums certified
platinum in the uk
56 times my first record came out when i
was 19.
i'm now 36 and it's amazing
we were leaving the mountain you just
try and work as hard as you can
you make the best records you possibly
can and watch as the wideness
[Music]
her latest was released this fall simply
titled
album number eight what has it been like
launching an album in the pandemic
it has been just full of every day is
a new experience took my heart
and lifted it to the stars
to the sky but katie malua is no
stranger to dealing with life's
challenges being seven years old and
having sort of rationed bread cueing
in the bread line that makes you realize
you know you really can't take anything
for granted malua was born in the soviet
republic of georgia
in 1984. as a little girl she had a
front row seat for the downfall of the
soviet union
and the ensuing georgian civil war they
were really happy years
despite the whole country coming to a
standstill
there was no electricity there was no
hot water i'd go downstairs like four
flights of stairs
get the water from the yard and then
take it back up
and that was just life malua discovered
pop music during the family's one hour
of available electricity
when her uncles would listen to led
zeppelin and queen
on a cassette player then in the evening
time when the lights were off
my mom would sit at the piano she would
play big beethoven's moonlight sonata
and so i think because of the darkness
and because of the lack of visual
stimulation i was just really aware of
the
incredible emotional effect of a piece
of music and what it can do to just
change your state
and her paternal grandmother helped her
find the emotion
in her own voice this was my grandma
tamar as soon as my focus would slightly
go
she could tell and she would say you
know katie you're not singing from the
heart you have to always sing from the
heart
when she was eight malua's family moved
to the united kingdom
where she'd learned english and
discovered literature
reading and learning to write was a
really big deal to me
it was actually just what literature was
able to do to me that blew my
mind and i have to say since i started
making records
it's the words that i feel
are my instrument your longing is
prides herself on being the lyricist for
all ten
songs on album number eight a first for
her to prepare
she went back to school i actually took
um
a bunch of lyric courses but i did find
it interesting that
doing lyrics only didn't seem quite
enough for me so i
enrolled onto a short fiction course
here in england
but in a sign of the times it was malua
alone
who created the album cover shot thanks
to the pandemic
and i'd never used a film camera before
and i had to learn
over zoom and the front cover ended up
being the shot that i took
of me looking at myself in the mirror
this year
there are no rules like they don't need
to be any rules and
you know you can just evolve and you can
learn and eventually you'll get to
wherever it is you're trying to get to